we are just eight days from the start of
the Winter Olympics in South Korea some
big movement today on two fronts Russia
may be getting some of its banned
athletes back and North Korea sends more
of its athletes across one of the
world's most heavily protected borders
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Greg PAL kaat has our story
Olympic diplomacy on the Korean
Peninsula North Korean athletes arriving
in South Korea ahead of next week's
Winter Olympics and beyond Jane skier
skaters and others from the North
participating with those from the south
along with joint cultural events the aim
is to improve tense relations between
the two countries the opening ceremony
will not only stage the traditional but
also the modern culture of South Korea
as well as performances integrating both
cultures still this snowy peacemaking is
hitting bumps North Korea has already
canceled one event north of the DMZ and
there are reports the Kim jong-un regime
will stage a military parade in
Pyongyang just before the opening
ceremony it could feature missiles now
threatening the US while Washington
supports the sport fueled Korean
outreach it is deploying fresh military
hardware nearby all options on the table
and by all options I think you have to
say it will it has to include military
options there could be other political
thawing 28 Russian athletes had doping
bands reversed and results from the last
Winter Olympics reinstated by a sporting
tribunal still International Olympic
Committee officials say that doesn't
necessarily mean they can join other
Russian athletes at the games or that it
will restore Russia's tarnished sporting
reputation since the Russian Olympic
Committee is suspended Russian athletes
can participate in Pyeongchang only on
invitation by the IOC the joint us-south
Korea military exercises are on hold
until after the Olympics some fear that
North Korea might restart some of its
dangerous games at that time as well
Brett creep Alcott in London Gregg thank
you